hi everyone welcome to the homeroom live
stream sal here from khan academy very
excited about today's
guest hassan minaj and i encourage
everyone watching on facebook or youtube
if you have questions for husso or
myself
feel free to start put putting those
questions in the message board below and
i'll we will get to as many of those as
possible
but before we jump into the conversation
i'll give my standard announcement
reminder to everyone
that khan academy is a not-for-profit
organization we can only exist
through donations philanthropic
donations from folks like yourself so if
in a position to do so please think
about going to khan academy.org
donate i also want to give a special
shout out to several organizations that
stepped up
you can imagine even before kovid khan
academy was running at a deficit and
then
covet hit our traffic became 300 percent
of normal
and uh we our deficit grew even larger
and so a special thanks to
bank of america google.org att fastly
novartis amgen foundation others
who've helped us close that gap but we
still have one so any help
you can provide is very much appreciated
so with that i am
super excited to introduce our guest
hassan minaj
i think uh probably doesn't need much of
an introduction for a lot of folks
uh but you know i i consider hussein you
know
me and my entire family are huge fans uh
he's kind of one of the
um actors comedians entertainers of our
time
uh known for the patriot act homecoming
king he was a correspondent on
on the daily show so uh thanks for so
much for joining husson
thanks for having me sal so maybe you'll
good
a lot that i mean a lot to your family
that was uh that was a very warm welcome
oh well it means a lot that it means a
lot to you that it means a lot to my
family but
let me let let me let let's just start
off a little bit
on i think something that you've
addressed a lot in your in your
in your in your speeches or your comedy
but i think especially as a as a south
asian i think it has a lot of resonance
i i'm
suspecting that we're going to have a
lot of south asians especially uh tuning
in today
is this what you expected you were going
to do when you were
a teenager or when you were younger did
you think you were going to be an
entertainer
no not at all man like uh
look i was just like every other desi
kid growing up i was pre-med i failed at
pre-med then i tried to do pre-law
uh i took the i took the lsat i lied to
my parents and then
um i started doing comedy so no i had no
idea that i'd be able to have a career
doing this and i still
don't fully believe it
and just to clarify some terminology the
word you just used
desi it means depending on on the
language in the indian subcontinent in
bengali but it's
it means someone from your country but
it generally refers to people from from
the
south asian indian from continental
asian diaspora yes
exactly exactly and and
so what was it you know given that there
weren't a lot of other folks
from you know essentially the same
heritage from our background going into
entertainment
what was it about you you know that you
said hey maybe this is something i can
do was it a talent you had what did
people say you're really funny you
should be a comedian
or just like that's the life i want um
no so look i grew up like a lot of kids
where
uh we didn't have cable television at
home so
i wasn't a pop culture junkie as a kid
uh but i was really into speech and
debate
that was one of the things i was
naturally kind of good at and i found
when i was doing speech and debate
tournaments
and public speaking tournaments in high
school i just naturally had an
inclination to
either make fun of the prompt or the
person that i was debating and every
time i did that
judges would give me 10 to 15 points
higher because they're just parents who
are bored out of their minds
and so the fact that like some skinny
basic kid is making fun of someone in a
high school gym is really funny to them
and i didn't realize until later when i
got to college and i actually started
watching stand-up comedy
it clicked for me in that moment my
freshman year i was like oh
stand-up comedy is just funny speech and
debate and so
everything else i had really kind of
failed at i wasn't that great at it
you know um i i used to work at safeway
i got fired from safeway i used to work
at officemax i walked fired from
officemax
um i used to work at a tech company i
got fired from that tech company just
i was really not good at anything else
well you're a step better than me
actually in my first jobs i remember i
applied for both mcdonald's and wendy's
and i didn't even
get get the job so at least at least you
got your foot in the door
did you lie on your application or were
you just like really straightforward at
all
no i i mean you know i was just looking
for some extra money i don't
i don't know why i would lie on on the
application but yeah at least you got
the you got the job i am curious why do
you think you got
fired and i suspect you might be
exaggerating but but why did you get
fired
so with safeway i i was stressed out one
day and i just
kind of snapped at work that wasn't good
um and then at officemax i was supposed
to sell printers
and so whenever someone comes into the
store you're supposed to say welcome to
officemax
how can i help you take it to the max
and um
there used to be people from my school
that would come in and this girl that i
had a huge crush on she came into office
max one day
and i just didn't say it and my manager
was like
hey you gotta say it and i'm like i
don't want to say it
well you gotta say it and he he really
saw that as like mutiny
um and then i got one of those like that
hassan can you come to the back please
it's on to the back and i was like oh
[ __ ] i'm gonna have to turn in
[Music]
okay yeah so those were legitimate
firings
when i had graduated college i had been
doing stand-up for about four years at
that point
from my freshman year i'm in my early
20s and i
i moved to san francisco they had a
great comedy scene there um
and i and i worked at a tech company and
i just wasn't getting my work done and i
remember my manager telling me you're
very capable but it seems like you want
to be somewhere else
and i was like yeah i kind of want to be
somewhere else and
it was a mutual thing where you know she
was like this is not the right fit you
should probably go
and then i mean you might know the cell
very well in silicon valley
someone walks you out of the building so
like an attorney like some sort of like
hr attorney guy had to walk me out of
the building
down the street to the coffee bean in
palo alto and then gave me my severance
check
it was really weird and i was like why
did you do that he's like well sometimes
when we fire employees people go postal
we have to do this like smash computers
then we had to do this out of like
safety and i was kind of touched that he
thought
a 155 pound indian dude would
wreak havoc inside of a those are the
guys you got to worry about the most
yeah i was i actually took it as a
compliment i'm like i'm looking really
big in these mediums if you think that
i'm a threat
yeah i've never had the walk i have
definitely been in conversations where
we thought about whether we had to do
the walk
but then we decided that that was not
appropriate we decided we trusted the
person that you know
uh but but but you know on on your
on your career you know a lot of times
when you look at someone like yourself
and you're like oh he realized he was
funny he realized he had a gift he
started doing stand up and then he
becomes hassan minaj
did it work that way or was it there was
it was a little bit difficult
now let me ask you an honest question
you're we're from the same background
out of
all your cousins and out of your entire
kandan are you the smartest
you're you're definitely the most
successful but were you the smartest
no i i would say growing up my sister
was what's the one what's your sister's
name
pharah so everybody's like farah's so
smart
as far as the best right
did you ever feel like everything that
you do you're just diet pharah
academically yeah i would say for about
the first 14 years of my life i started
getting fair
parody when i was like 15 but people
still didn't see it i knew it
but they didn't see it because my brand
had been defined
got it yeah so for me look i had a lot
of
really really smart intelligent cousins
that my little sister she's way smarter
than me she went to an ivy league school
all of those things
and so i quickly realized as i was you
know in my 20s
um i can try to run this race with them
uh but i will always be a diet version
of aisha i'm not going to
i'm not going to beat her at
standardized testing i'm not going to
beat her at
these certain things i'm really good at
these other things and
society didn't necessarily value them
our community definitely didn't value
them
um but i found value in them and i felt
like
i had a natural inclination for it um
the same way there's certain kids i
remember in calculus bc they just got it
like
math they just got it verbal they got it
they could just
ingest tons of material understand it
and then regurgitate it back out
i had that with public speaking or
thinking about a quick joke on the fly
or constructing a funny story um and so
i just said look i'm gonna be the best
version of myself and i'm gonna just go
all
in on comedy um and really
uh after a while i didn't have a high
enough self-esteem
ego or just outlook on life where i felt
like
anything else was going to work out for
me in that way so i just decided to
kind of put med school and law school
hustle into this comedy thing
and then i became very lucky that's
really what it is it's not
dude it might just work i got very lucky
but what i am curious about when you
took that leap as and as we've talked
about already
it's it's not the standard leap
especially from folks from our community
uh i mean you really are one of the
pioneers here when you started it did
you have moments of
doubt where you're just like oh maybe
this was the mistake maybe my parents
were right or whatever else
yeah so there were some seminal moments
for me um i remember 2004
uh i was walking around davis that's the
town that i grew up and i went to uc
davis
um i know there's probably people that
are watching that are very disappointed
but
you know i got a 13 10 on the sat
so i was at you amazing how many people
are asking about your sats
i don't know if this is a thing but i'm
trying to edit it out
and i got a 1310 and we can include this
in the chat i retook it
on the show just as a joke and i did
worse
it's interesting i mean it tells you a
lot about our community how many south
asians are asking about your sat scores
the fact that i'm willing to admit it
means that i'm a vanguard and i'm brave
they're they're very they're like wow um
but i was walking around downtown davis
i see the poster for harold and kumar go
to white castle
and i saw john cho and calpin on that
poster and i remember going into the
movie theater
and people were laughing and it was
packed and
it was this like seminal college weed
movie which i didn't think was possible
and there was two asian leads they
weren't stereotypical
um and the movie became this cult
classic
and that was one of the first times
where i thought oh this is possible
then in 2005 my sophomore year
russell peters had a big video you know
that started going viral of him doing
stand-up comedy
and i had been open-miking for about a
year and a half at that point and i
couldn't believe it he was coming
to ucla to perform
at one of their big auditoriums and i
drove from sacramento
to la i've never told russell the story
but i should tell him the story i paid
88
and i stood way in the back of this
auditorium and i watched him and he was
wearing a white blazer i'll never forget
this
chris spencer opened for him he's
wearing a white blazer and i just i
could not believe there were 1800 people
in this theater
and he was you know talking about his
family and talking about his life
and it just it really clicked for me in
that moment that it was possible that
this kind of weird superpower that i had
it actually was valued by society it was
seen by society and you could actually
make a living doing it
and then you know the next 15 years of
my life was just figuring out am i good
enough to
actually make a living doing it but i
just came to terms with i really
i really loved the art form and i loved
the craft of it
and you were all in you never were you
know there weren't moments where you're
like oh maybe i'm
i'm gonna go back to what what the
family wants me to do yeah there were a
few moments i remember
when i when my lsat score was expiring
that was a big deal it was five years
after i graduated college and that was a
real tough conversation with my parents
that i wasn't gonna go then they made me
go they made me not go but they made me
apply
and i ended up deferring my admission
and then when they asked me hey are you
gonna come back or not
i ended up you know turning it down and
so there were
you know these big kind of speed bumps
along the way but
you know i kind of disappointed my
parents like through snake venom it was
about an eight year process for the
venom of disappointment to kick in and
for them to give up on me and to move on
to aisha
and and you know you have kids right how
many kids do you have
i have three kids eleven nine and five
and a half yeah i mean
you're gonna have to give up on one of
them perhaps like i got two i mean who's
going to be the golden one how many
franchise picks do you have
you know that's right that's why you
need you know you need a little bit of a
portfolio just so
you know one wonderful fully disappoint
you distribute in your roth ira you know
what i mean
exactly exactly what was the moment
that you were kind of accepted was it
was it the gig at the daily show
that your parents were like oh we knew
all along we had a gifted son
yeah so you know 2014 when john hired me
at the daily show
it was it was a real seminal moment for
me
in terms of just like respect from uh
the community the comedy community
my parents because you know it's very
rare that you get to do things that are
both funny and meaningful
like there's a lot of things that you do
in show business that are just like
just sheer funny and then there's things
that are just pure like
philanthropy that are meaningful and jon
stewart kind of represented the
culmination of both
and the show is an institution it's like
snl it's so
getting hired to be at the daily show
was this moment for especially my family
to be like
look he i think i think he he should do
this as a career
at that point i was already what 10
years
one month nine days into doing stand-up
comedy so
it was what it was and what two
questions what did you what do you think
jon stewart saw in you uh was he right
i think that is a hater do you mean that
genuinely like is it a positive
possibility
i mean a very positive way i if i was a
hater i wouldn't you know
we wouldn't be talking right now i think
uh i think
um i think he really loves taken
perspective
and when i i um when i
when i knew that you know michael che
had
been hired to join saturday night live
there was an opening at the show
and when i submitted my audition tape i
just
felt like i felt very uniquely
positioned i felt like i could be on the
show i really do feel like i would be a
good fit
and so i made my own audition tape i
made my own field piece
and i sent it to them it was almost like
a proof of concept and
they loved it and they had me come in
and do a screen test
and i remember from my screen test i
really wanted to swing for the fences
and so
i took some big chances and the screen
test i made fun of john i just
i i took some liberties even in the
script that i had submitted them
and um now that i look back on it and
maybe one day i'll put it up on youtube
or something so people can see
i'm really glad that i i stuck to my
guns
uh i made fun of the boss in front of
everybody um and i swung for the fences
i wasn't trying to get a single i tried
to hit this thing over the fence
and and get a home run and and once you
were on the show you know what did you
learn there what did you learn from jon
stewart or the other folks on the show
um i realized that take is more
important than jokes
one of the things i learned early on was
when john would walk into the 9 15 a.m
meeting
he wasn't trying to be funny he really
was
distilling his opinion into two or three
sentences
and then we would build the entire show
around that and that's the most
important thing
for comedy you're making a funny
argument but at the core what is your
argument
and so great jokes at their at their
essence are great philosophical
positions
said in a funny way and i think that is
what really separated the daily show
uh from the rest of the pack i mean you
know in the early 2000s
it became a lot of people started to
realize that they were giving in some
ways more
uh truthful information than a lot of
what you were getting in the rest of the
media
do you see that as part of you know when
when you look you know
30 40 50 years back on on your career
are you saying hey
i'm going to be happy if i just
entertained a bunch of folks are you
saying no i also want to change society
yeah so look comedy isn't medicine
medicine is medicine
um so you hear a lot of debates about
like
why didn't this song change the world or
hey if if if this person was still on
the air
you know donald trump wouldn't be
president none of those things are true
i think art is a true reflection of the
times and
and my goal you know sal you get this
i'll button it with this
is i use comedy as an art form to
understand myself
and so the the work that i do is to to
present my thoughts and my viewpoint of
the world
to people so that they feel seen so that
i feel seen and i feel understood i want
to connect with people
and i want to explain the human
condition through comedy and ultimately
i want to say how i really feel in my
heart and not be a dark book
so if 20 30 40 years from now i look
back on my life and i was like i was in
a dirt book and i really said it
i really said it and you look back on
you know our show
i'm proud of our saudi arabia episode
i'm proud of our indian elections
episode i'm proud of our
student loans episode because we swung
for it you know and
um that's what it's really about for me
no it's powerful and and just to
translate do more technical jargon and
i'm i'm not the most qualified person to
translate hindi but tarpook means
kind of scary
[Laughter]
you know sal i know you're the khan
academy guy but i also don't want to
explain myself
like i want to be the most authentic
version of myself
and so i want to make the world a bigger
place instead of trying to bend and try
to
communicate and explain my culture point
of view to people
i want to bring you into my world and
make people feel like that and so
i think that's when the show's at its
best and honestly audiences are really
smart and savvy
they want to have an authentic real
experience
and i'll say i'll just speak for myself
very personally you know i think i grew
up i'm a little bit older than you i
think i'm 9 or 10 years older than you
but in you know my generation so to
speak
you know it was kind of like well i'll
just i'll just keep that to myself um
yeah
you know i'll just try my best to fit in
and but you know what when i
when i saw your netflix special
homecoming king and obviously a lot of
your episodes of patriot act
there is a little bit of me that kind of
got unlocked i'm like yeah
yeah that's right i shouldn't be
hiding that as much the game used to be
in your generation really fought for
this where
assimilation was the win my generation
really
i'm trying to say authenticity is the
win
and i think hopefully for my kids and
the younger
i see these young comics coming up they
don't even need to introduce themselves
when they walk into the room
and i love that they don't even need to
provide the backstory
you know i feel like a lot of what the
generation before me was providing was
the prequel
they had to tell the story of our
parents they had to tell the story of
our community
and i think now there's a whole bunch of
like
young kids that are out there making
really cool work
uh on the internet where they don't have
to introduce themselves to the world
they don't have they don't have to carry
that baggage and i think i think the art
that they're going to make is going to
be even that much more interesting
yeah and and there's a lot of questions
coming in this is from instagram
um this is a mooji says
as a fellow brown indian how do you deal
with racism during school and and i'll
ask that in a broader context obviously
race is a very big topic right now in
our society and you've you've
you've spoken about it in i think very
interesting ways especially because
you know we are a lot of the the
dialogue is around black versus white
sometimes people will say brown but
brown might may or may not apply to
south asians or not
right how have you thought about it um
and and in a lot of your your your shows
you've definitely brought up race
as a major yeah you know we we did a big
episode about george floyd and the
murder of george floyd and really like
the asian americans community
you know our community's involvement and
all of that and for the longest time
like you said sal
race has been seen as a black white
issue in this country and our community
has been like where's our
where's our place in all of that and one
of the things that i wanted to explain
was
you know for a lot of us were
descendants of the 1965 immigration act
so
because of that piece of legislation
signed by lyndon b johnson and martin
luther king jr
you know are ami and our booze were able
to come here in the 70s and 80s
uh to to get educational opportunities
so we could be here and
and live in silicon valley and live in
fremont milipedes et cetera right and so
um that that was important for me to
connect the dots and say no we
we're integrate we're integrally linked
to the civil rights movement in this
country and we were cc'd on that email
so it's our job to be actively involved
in the social change that we want to see
in the world
yeah what i often point to family
members and you know you you've often
talked about even the
the racism that exists within our
community uh which is sometimes quite
strong
but what i always like to remind folks
in our community is that
our lives would be very different if not
for the civil rights movement i think a
lot of uh
south asians kind of say yeah we we
we've assimilated we've you know where
we got these houses in the suburbs we're
doctors and and lawyers and engineers
but if you did not have the very hard
work of the civil rights movement one
the immigration act wouldn't pass but
even if even if our parents were able to
immigrate to this country
their lives would have been very
different if not for desegregation and
things like that
i'm not trying to be i think people have
these very
intellectual arguments about it where
they go yeah but look at what i did in
my life
really what a lot of the stuff the
conversation that's happening right now
about different communities and people
being wanna be
folks want to be heard it's an empathy
argument
people are really hurting right now man
like unemployment is at an all-time high
people are really suffering and
what's happening right now both the
social and the hopefully i think the
economic reckoning that's going to be
happening
is people want to be heard and i think
we have to be empathetic to hear the
life experiences of other people
yeah absolutely well i want to make sure
i get enough que there's so many
questions coming
in from youtube uh so this is from lizzy
omobude and you know we talked a little
bit about it it starts off with mr minaj
did your parents support you we talked a
bit about that but if not
how did you get them to deal with it
because i'm about to start studying
medicine and i really feel that it's not
where i'm meant to be
but my parents i think it didn't
complete but my parents want me to i'm
assuming is what lizzy's saying right
i think those tough conversations are
really hard to have but
i've told this to a lot of kids and a
lot of people that have turned to me for
advice
when you transition into adulthood
there's probably going to be two major
decisions that you have to make and they
may be
really really tough to talk about with
your parents who you choose to love
and what you choose to do with your
profession
those two hills are worth dying on i'll
say that unequivocally
everything else just everything else
just side with your parents
they want you to come there for
thanksgiving your challah wants you to
do this
your chachi wants you to do that do it
like just be like fine i'll do it
those two those two fights are worth
having
that's super powerful and what would you
say to the because i know people even in
my
look and i think we i've i faced it
myself you know
starting a not-for-profit caused
significant cognitive dissonance
you know becoming a doing stuff on
youtube 2005 created significant
cognitive dissonance with my family
uh and they're like well it seems
academic and related to computers so
that's good
but it literally says not profit
there's no money there's nobody
remember how can we flex on other people
in the community
this is really bad like i
no i would like to claim that i don't
have a fragile male ego but i remember
going to dinner parties in 2005 2000
well actually 2009 when i quit my
very acceptable job as an investment
analyst at a hedge fund
right and i'd go to dinner parties
primarily south asian dinner parties
and you know i've heard people i i
literally had this one moment where uh
after i
explained what i did for a living but i
was living off of savings at the time
uh you know the the the the couple i
heard them in earshot saying thank god
his wife is training to be a physician
and you know that was definitely a a
punch in the gut
yeah but i think if like look if kovid
has exposed anything now that we're all
just like holed up at home
who are we stunting for anyways yeah
like
if if you shape if you make major life
decisions that are going to impact your
life for the next 10 to 15 years like
med school
which is a 10 to 12 year proposition
plus all the time that you have to work
and the debt you have just to stunt
on some random auntie and natomas good
god man that ain't worth it like it just
ain't worth it and i remember like my
freshman year when i was pre-med i
thought
it wouldn't be worth it but it's not and
so
i'm not saying that it doesn't hurt like
you know being made fun of in the
sacramento community that's
not fun like being told the decisions
you're making are wrong or
being told like hearing you know people
whisper like i hope you don't i pray
that you don't end up
like that you know like that's hurtful
but um i don't know like
also waking up and loving what you do
and feeling purpose in it
also i don't know it just means to me it
means more to me than that
yeah super powerful you got you got one
life i mean the time has gone by i i
i we could talk for hours but i'll just
let you on kind of a final word there's
a lot of
questions about breaking into comedy
your inspiration
yeah you know finish it however you like
but you know this general thing of
life advice for kids how do you pursue
your passion i mean you've already
touched on it a bit you know how do you
keep that stick-to-itiveness uh to to to
get to where you want to go in life and
have real purpose
yeah i think i think a really
interesting thing i got two kids i have
a two-year-old
and i have a a newborn who's five
uh you know five months old now and
the biggest thing that i wanted to
change from the time i was a kid to now
now i'm a father like the simba mufasa
relationship
is for our parents they saw us children
as property
like you are my investment and i need to
move you
i need to move you within the s p 500
the way
you need to return on investment for me
i want to look at them less as an owner
i want to be more as somebody who guides
them and pulls their
their talents and their gifts out of
them and it's important
um if i was giving advice to again
16 17 18 year old hassan i would
basically say
i wouldn't ask him what do you want to
do because people ask that all the time
hey what do you want to do what are your
dreams
i would say write down what are your
gifts meaning what are the things that
you do
or even if you rolled out of bed you
would be better than everybody else in
your class
that's your gift and it can be something
stupid
it can be video games it could be like
two-hand touch
it could be running track it could be
any of those things but
what is that natural alacrity that you
have
where you're better better than
everybody in your class in your
community
you can just do it in your sleep you
know i used to have a friend
we would play pickup basketball he could
dunk
two-handed in timberland booths while he
was drinking mountain dew code red
he had a gift you know what i mean like
if i
if i had a whopper in mountain dew code
red there's no way i'm running line
drills
but my buddy purnell could just two-hand
dunk like that
in booths and cargos like and he had a
gift for the for that thing
and so i think the key is is figuring
out what your gifts are
and then applying work ethic to that i
wasn't gifted at math i wasn't gifted
at certain subjects in school that
wasn't my gift i could work hard at it
but there's a cap and so
try to find what your gift is and don't
be ashamed if it's a weird thing
that's super powerful and i think
there's another layer to that which is i
think there's more outlets for more
gifts than maybe at any other time in
history
uh as your story highlights in some ways
mine and many many other folks right now
you know what the encouraging thing is
it's just the beginning like
there are people that are on youtube
that do unboxing videos
that are just you know savants of their
craft
right there's professional people that
play video games though there's so many
different
ways to be unique or interesting
i have a friend who has a great voice
for podcasting and he has an incredible
podcast
like those are things that just didn't
exist five years ago and so
try to look at your what your gifts are
stop trying to be somebody
else and figure out what those gifts are
and i think if there ever was a time
to really understand what those things
are now's the time
yeah super powerful and and and i think
you know very very wise words for for
everyone listening at
all ages uh husson thanks so much for
joining this this was a real treat i
hope we can do this again
thanks ah
well thanks thanks everyone for joining
another you know i
i thought really you know i never know
where these conversations are going to
go but i thought
there were some definite gems of wisdom
from hassan just now on you know just
how to live your life how do you live
your life with purpose
um and and how do you stick to
uh uh what you believe in and and your
gifts in the world so i thought that was
a very powerful i'm i'm gonna make sure
my kids hear that and i'm gonna make
sure that i as a parent
don't fall into some of the traps that
uh you know at least
both us and i were talking about uh that
you sometimes see
i'm super excited about tomorrow's guest
nicole hannah jones
a journalist and author of the 1619
project
uh the 16 19 16 19 is the year that
slavery came to the americas
uh so obviously a very relevant topic to
uh the work the world what's going on in
the world uh as we speak
uh but uh regardless super excited to
have all of y'all join us and uh i will
see you tomorrow
you